>> Tucker: FOR TWO YEARS, DONALD
TRUMP JR. HAS LIVED THE VERY
HEART OF THE RUSSIA STORY, WHICH
WE NOW WAS A CONSPIRACY THEORY
FOR ATTENDING A MEETING WITH A
RUSSIAN LAWYER NOBODY HAS HEARD
OF.
MANY SUGGESTED HE WOULD DIE IN
PRISON.
WE KNOW NONE OF THAT WAS REAL.
THEY WERE LYING.
IT WAS NOT TRUE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO PRISON.
DONALD TRUMP JOINS US TONIGHT.
DONALD TRUMP, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
CAN RECALL THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT I HEARD THAT YOU WOULD BE
INDICTED.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE INDICTED.
>> I HAVE NOT BUT IT'S THOUSANDS
IF NOT MORE THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT IS THE
EXPERIENCE LIKE?
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE YOU RIGHT
NOW?
>> FEELS GREAT.
I WAS A BIG PART OF THIS GOING
ON.
I'M THE ONE THAT TOOK THE DAILY
INCOMING, THE NONSENSE.
AT THE SAME TIME, I WAS THE
PERSON THAT WAS THERE.
I WAS ACTUALLY IN THE ROOM.
SO I UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING THAT
WENT INTO IT.
I REALIZED WE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE OTHER SIDE WAS DOING, YOU
REALIZE IT WAS THEM COLLUDING,
NOT US.
WE WERE DOING A CAMPAIGN.
WE WERE FUNCTIONING LIKE ANY
CAMPAIGN WOULD.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID.
SO IT WAS DIFFICULT TO WATCH.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO WATCH WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO AND HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO DO TO MY FATHER FOR
TWO YEARS.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS WITH THEIR
MEDIA LACKEYS CREATING A
NARRATIVE THAT THEY WANT TO BE
TRUE BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
EXPLAIN THE OUTCOME OF THE LAST
ELECTION.
MY FATHER WON.
HE WAS ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE FOR THEM IN A WAY THAT
BARACK OBAMA COULDN'T COME CLOSE
TO DOING.
BY THE WAY, IT'S NOT JUST A
PARTISAN ISSUE.
BUSH COULDN'T HAVE DONE IT
EITHER.
MY FATHER HAS DONE INCREDIBLE
THINGS.
HE'S DONE THINGS FOR WORKING
CLASS AMERICANS.
YOU HAVE ALL-TIME LOW AFRICAN
AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT, ALL-TIME
LOW HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT.
ALL-TIME LOW FEMALE
UNEMPLOYMENT.
HE'S DOING THAT WITH THIS BUBBLE
AROUND HIM FOR TWO YEARS.
THINK OF WHAT HE COULD DO
WITHOUT THAT NOISE.
>> Tucker: SO WHAT I NEVER
UNDERSTAND, IF YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH THE POLICIES OR THE
CAMPAIGN BEFORE IT ON TRADE,
IMMIGRATION, PICK A TOPIC, WHY
NOT DEBATE THEM?
THE RUSSIA STORY SEEMED TO
SUBSUME THAT.
NOBODY TALKED ABOUT THE
POLICIES.
SOME POLICIES WEREN'T GETTING
DONE BECAUSE OF IT.
WHY NOT HAVE A CONVENTIONAL
POLITICAL DEBATE?
>> THE DEMOCRAT CAN'T WIN WITH
THEIR IDEAS.
WITH THE ISSUES AND THE THINGS
THAT THEY WANT TO PUSH, THEY
DON'T WORK.
THEY TRIED THAT UNDER OBAMA.
THEY'RE TRYING THAT WITH THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, WE DON'T
HAVE 93 TRILLION TO SPEND TO SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE A BUS TO
HAWAII.
THAT DOESN'T WORK.
THEIR IDEAS DON'T WORK.
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT.
SO THE WAY TO COMBAT THAT IS TO
DEMONIZE THAT IS GETTING IT DONE
WITH IDEAS THAT THEY CAN'T
STAND.
THAT'S WHAT MY FATHER HAS BEEN
DOING.
>> Tucker: THIS WASN'T -- THE
RUSSIA STORY WASN'T ABOUT YOUR
FATHER.
IT WAS ABOUT THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM, VERY MUCH INCLUDING YOU.
YOU WERE A MAJOR FIGURE IN THIS
NARRATIVE.
>> YEAH, I WAS THE NEEDLE IN THE
HAY STACK.
WE HANDED OVER OUR E-MAILS.
I DID 27 SOMETHING HOURS OF
TESTIMONY IN FRONT OF
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED?
YOU GO IN THE MEETING AT THE EOF
SEVEN HOURS, GUYS, DO YOU HAVE
ANYMORE QUESTIONS?
GO LOOK AT THE RECORDS.
DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS?
NO, WE HAVE KNOWN.
GUYS LIKE DICK BLUMENTHAL GO OUT
ON THE STEPS AND SAY THERE'S
MANY QUESTIONS THAT WERE NOT
ANSWERED.
IT'S NONSENSE.
IT'S A GAME.
YOU HAVE THE LEADER OF THE TIN
FOIL HAT BRIGADE, ADAM SCHIFF
TALKING ABOUT THE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
HE'S LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE'S DOING IT EVERY DAY ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION.
HE'S GOTTEN MORE AIR TIME
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH THAN MICHAEL
AVENATTI, BUT THEY'RE ABOUT OF
THE SAME LEVEL OF CREDIBILITY
AND THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THAT, TUCKER.
WHEN YOU'RE ON THAT SIDE, YOU
HAVE THE MEDIA CARRYING YOUR
WATER FOR YOU, YOU CAN SAY
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
WHEN YOU'RE ON OUR SIDE, EVEN
WHEN YOU'RE RIGHT, EVEN WHEN
YOU'RE PROVEN SO, THERE'S A
LEVEL OF CULPABILITY.
>> Tucker: SO SINCE THERE'S
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS PEOPLE
THAT BELIEVE YOU'RE A RUSSIAN
AGENT, THE MOST SERIOUS CHARGE
YOU CAN LEVEL AGAINST ANYBODY
BETRAYING YOUR COUNTRY, HOW HAS
THAT AFFECTED -- WHAT IS IT LIKE
WHEN YOU GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE?
>> NEW YORK CITY, IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
OBVIOUSLY.
THE REALITY IS THIS.
I'M A PATRIOT TRUE AND TRUE.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
I LOVE EVERYTHING IT STANDS FOR.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME,
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH, THE SON OF A
BILLIONAIRE FROM NEW YORK CITY,
UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS, I SPEND A
LOT OF TIME IN MIDDLE AMERICA,
WHETHER MY HOBBIES, SHOOTING,
FISHING, I KNOW THOSE PEOPLE.
GUESS HAVE ASKED ABOUT RUSSIA?
ZERO.
THEY KNOW THAT IT'S NONSENSE.
THIS IS THE MEDIA'S CLASSIC
MOVE.
THEY TAKE THE NARRATIVE THEY
UNDERSTAND AND THEIR NEW YORK
AND D.C. BUBBLES AND THEY TRY TO
SELL THAT TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY GETS IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SEE?
THEY SEE MANUFACTURING JOBS
COMING BACK TO THIS COUNTRY.
THEY SEE THEIR WAGES RISING FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES.
THEY SEE THE STOCK MARKET AND
THEIR 401(k)s AT ALL-TIME HIGHS.
THEY SEE ALL-TIME LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRAT PLATFORM?
DO THE OPPOSITE OF ANYTHING THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE.
IF DONALD TRUMP CAME OUT TODAY
IN FAVOR OF OXYGEN, THE LEFT
WOULD BE AGAINST IT.
DO THEY REALLY WANT TO REVERSE
THE SUCCESSES THAT WE HAVE SEEN?
ALL-TIME LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR ALL OF THE
MINORITIES LISTED?
>> Tucker: SO THAT
CONVERSATION -- CAN WE BEGIN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT POLICY NOW?
WHAT HAPPENED SINCE --
PRESUMABLY AT SOME POINT THEY'LL
ACKNOWLEDGE REALITY, WHICH IS
MUELLER CLEARED THE
ADMINISTRATION OF COLLUSION
CHARGES.
>> I DOUBT THEY EVER DO THAT.
IT'S NOT THEIR STYLE.
AGAIN, THERE'S NO ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THEIR SIDE.
>> Tucker: TRUE.
>> TWO THINGS HAVE TO HAPPEN.
WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO HOW THIS
ALL STARTED.
OKAY?
THIS DIDN'T START WITH SOME FBI
AGENT.
THIS STARTED WITH A LAWYER
BUREAUCRATS AT THE TOP OF THE
FBI WORKING WITH HILLARY
CLINTON, FUSION GPS, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, PETER STRZOK.
THOSE PEOPLE NEED TO BE LOOKED
INTO.
THIS WAS THE GREATEST FARCE EVER
PERPETRATED ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
IT'S A DISGRACE AND IT'S A STAIN
ON OUR CONSTITUTION.
WE HAVE TO FIX THAT.
THEN WHAT I'D LIKE, I'D LIKE US
ALL TO GET TOGETHER.
LET'S START WORKING -- HOW ABOUT
WE PASS SOME BILLS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE?
WHY DON'T THE DEMOCRATS GET
TOGETHER WITH THE REPUBLICANS
AND MY FATHER AND ACTUALLY START
DOING AND CONTINUING THE AMAZING
THINGS THAT MY FATHER HAS BEEN
DOING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
THAT'S WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT KIND OF
UNITY.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THE DEMOCRATS
FOCUSING ON WHAT IS GOOD FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, NOT JUST
SCREAMING ON TV TRYING TO
PERPETUATE A HOAX AND A MYTH
THAT THEY THEMSELVES HAVE
CREATED.
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
NO CREDIBILITY RIGHT NOW.
THE ADAM SCHIFFS OF THE WORLD
HAVE NO CREDIBILITY RIGHT NOW
AND IT WILL TAKE YEARS FOR THEM
TO GAIN THAT BACK IF THEY DON'T
TRY TO ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING TO
EFFECTUATE CHANGE AND GET THINGS
MOVING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MY FATHER DID AMAZING THINGS
WITH THIS STUFF GOING ON, WITH
THIS CLOUD OVER HIS HEAD.
IMAGINE WHAT HE COULD DO IF YOU
LET HIM DO HIS THING.
THEY MAY WANT TO SIT THIS OUT.
JUMP ON THE TRUMP TRAIN.
LET'S GET THIS THING GOING AND
LET'S KEEP THE WINNING.